pero no
estas imágenes le dieron la vuelta al
mundo
policías estadounidenses arrodillados
por todo el valle
un gesto fuerte para manifestar su
solidaridad frente a los crímenes
raciales perpetrados por algunos colegas
suyos el capitán ya alguien es oficial
de policía desde hace 17 años reconoce
que se necesitan reformas
cuando miro lo que ocurrió en mineápolis
y observo mi carrera quedó consternado
le garantizo que es válido para la
mayoría de nosotros
apoyamos totalmente el mensaje
transmitido por black light meter a la
policía en este país y en el mundo
entero puede aprender y evolucionar
y si podemos mejorar
we work with wolves
mejorar wanda cooper jones no cree en
ello esta mujer es la madre de aguantar
ver y el joven afroamericano de 25 años
asesinado a tiros por dos hombres
armados mientras trotaba en el barrio
residencial de bronze witten georgia
vienen al 'new age' alégrense busca
respuestas e inmediatamente la policía
me había descrito a adm out con culpable
como ladrón por un lado los blancos
decían que merecía lo que le ocurrió
porque había cometido un crimen y por
otro lado los negros leían los artículos
de prensa y trataban de entender y veían
que algo no era normal
arcos and stay borja pen de bright
los hechos ocurrieron el 23 de febrero
pero el asunto fue inicialmente tapado
por la justicia local resurgió tan solo
en mayo tras la difusión de este vídeo
en twitter
se ve a gregory ma el policía retirado
ya su hijo travis bajar de su camioneta
y dispararle a home and air berlin este
vídeo conduce al arresto de los dos
hombres quienes permanecieron en
libertad durante dos meses para wanda
hay una cosa segura el racismo ha sido
estimulado por el poder político
mira nuestro presidente de eeuu no ha
dirigido
ha dividido a negros y blancos cuando
fue elegido la gente como él se sintió
más desinhibida gente como los mcmichael
quienes nunca se hubieran imaginado ser
condenados por haber asesinado a mi hijo
tengo quiero verte
antes de la muerte de ahmad georgia era
uno de los únicos cuatro estados
estadounidenses que no reconocían la
noción de crimen de odio bajo la presión
de la calle desde entonces una ley fue
adoptada por el parlamento del estado
pero para la n
acp la asociación nacional por el avance
de las personas de color no es
suficiente
queremos impedir los asesinatos la
noción de crimen de odio permite
calificar un asesinato en cuanto tiene
lugar y hay un juicio en lo que le
solicitamos al cuerpo legislativo es una
ley que salve vidas y para ello se
necesita abrogar la ley que permite el
arresto ciudadano
porque esta ley autoriza a los
ciudadanos a detener a otros para
mantenerlos arrestados
en virtud de esta ley del arresto
ciudadano fue que los dos asesinos de
aguantar ver y actuaron redactada en
1863 esta ley les permite a los
ciudadanos detener a cualquiera que les
parezca sospechoso una ley ambigua y
arbitraria que conduce adherido a ser
racistas
no pudo defenderse fue detenido y
asesinado como un perro no es la primera
vez que sucede no ha sido el último caso
en georgia había otros desde entonces
por lo tanto hay mucho camino por
recorrer y lucharemos
en brunswick el 37% de la población vive
bajo el umbral de la pobreza para muchos
jóvenes la única perspectiva de futuro
es el fútbol americano
ajmal jugaba en esta cancha en el liceo
punto de la ciudad bajo la supervisión
del entrenador wang quien entrena a
jóvenes desde hace más de 15 años
[Música]
escuchas a hablar de asuntos como este
pero no es lo mismo cuando se trata de
un joven que has entrenado durante tres
años cuando me enteré de lo ocurrido me
partió el corazón porque en ahmad veo a
todos los jugadores que formó veo a mi
sobrino veo a todos estos jóvenes negros
a los que les gusta correr y entrenarse
en su comunidad y pienso lo peligroso
que puede ser
el entrenador para un monto un colectivo
corro con ajmán para movilizar a la
comunidad alrededor de la memoria del
joven
para el la muerte de ahmad albert y la
lentitud de la justicia frente al asunto
son emblemáticos del profundo problema
que persiste en la sociedad
norteamericana
la policía y los afroamericanos siempre
han tenido una relación complicada
durante la era jim crow en eeuu durante
la segregación eran policías que les
decían a los afroamericanos que no
podían sentarse en la cantina que no
podían beber agua de la misma fuente no
usar los mismos baños hay que crear un
cambio hay que hacer que nuestro país
cuente con los más altos estándares de
justicia social
a pesar de los años el espectro de la
segregación parece vagar en el viejo sur
estadounidense la cantidad de crímenes
de odio ha aumentado cada año desde hace
cuatro años en 2019 el 60% de estos
crímenes fue de carácter racial